[Music]
trooper micah may henry 6203
your end of watch 1042 time is july 29th
2021 at 10 43 hours
god speed sir
rest in peace we have it from here
remembering a fallen hero nevada highway
patrol micah may was laid to rest today
in an incredibly moving ceremony family
friends and law enforcement from across
the country came together for a funeral
procession and ceremonial burial sasha
loftis was there
hearts are still heavy tonight but those
who took part in today's events say
they're grateful for the opportunity to
honor trooper may and thank his family
for everything he gave
a father husband brother and son
nevada highway patrol trooper micah may
dedicated his days to selfless service
micah was a true silent guardian
with a warrior spirit in the week since
he lost his life in the line of duty
our city came together to remember his
courage and integrity this is our
opportunity to show his family how much
he meant to not just this agency but to
the las vegas community
[Music]
a funeral service symbolic procession
salute and burial held friday allowed
friends family and fellow law
enforcement to share his light and say
goodbye he's been up there
poking his head out from the clouds
and
taking daredevil leaps between them
while mischievously bringing rain and
rainbow to las vegas and though his days
here have ended those who loved trooper
may hope his legacy lives on now that
you know micah a bit more the way i did
it's easy to understand
why he was an amazing person as an
internal hero and a tireless protector
fallen but never forgotten trooper may
served with the nevada highway patrol
for 13 years he is survived by his wife
his two children his parents and his two
brothers if you would like to help his
family we have more information on our
website
8newsnow.com reporting in las vegas
tonight sasha loftis 8 news now